this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking another look at
Insurgency Sandstorm a bit of gameplay
footage there something that is not well
represented is breaching you don't
typically get that what we've just seen
which is blow out top hinge blow out
bottom hinge Doors door falls out that's
how shotgun breaching is or one way of
doing uh shotgun breaching if you like
this kind of content we've got a brand
new season of Loadout airing on the
channel right now new episodes will
launch every Sunday and you can already
check out our most recent episode all
about the pop culture footprint of the
P90 and of course make sure to subscribe
for our upcoming episode about how games
get the flamethrower wrong too right
let's take a look at the weapons of
Insurgency sandstorm
this is a very nice FN FAL so I have one
from the racks here at the Royal
armories and it's broadly the type that
we are seeing in the footage sheet metal
ribbed handguard with built-in bipod
which is actually a gameplay feature in
Insurgency which is really good now the
version I've chosen here this is
actually a German G1 the German G1 and
the Austrian sgg 58 early at least are
very very close so I'm not 100 sure
which one they're going for here this
one is a
well what was cool at the time at least
in English a sniper variant it's really
designated Marksman so you'd have a low
power magnification Optical sight one in
a squad or something like that so you'd
have to swap out the top cover with the
mount permanently attached and that's
the German equivalent is here so this
Mount is always attached to this piece
of sheet metal and you change over your
pieces of sheet metal if that makes
sense the reason I'm rabbiting about
that is that the game happily because a
lot of games with fals in just go
straight for a rail top cover I like the
old school iron sight look and then you
can change it in this game which is very
nice traditional wooden furniture I
think that one of the only little minor
nitpicks I would have with this model is
I don't think the pistol grip is quite
the right shape the angle on the back of
it's a little acute it's a bit thick
that's the first thing I noticed is the
fal grip is I suppose for
1955 to eight it's pretty comfortable at
least for me quite quite a steep rake to
it quite slim and that looks like a bit
of an old chunk that that may be a minor
issue
okay so they're calling this Alpha AK
now there was a project Alpha of some
sort in Russia but I believe that was
with the AK-74 platform big chunky rail
4 end that changes the profile I've gone
pretty drastically a few different
designs you use that and I believe that
was a feature of this loose project so
some of my um vagueness here is to do
with American cloners who have Loosely
recreated the same basic configuration
so new furniture including rail
handguard some sort of new muzzle device
a rail top cover and an M4 buffer tube
type butt stock so that's been done in a
generic sense with AKs which I think is
what this is really representing and
then there's this project Alpha which is
I think where the name is coming from
personally I cannot stand buffer tube
butt stocks on a case and that includes
the first generation ak-12 butt stock
that is not actually in simple type
stock it's not compatible at all with
that but it was inspired by and looks
awful and they've changed it this is
very much a conventional modern M4 type
bus stop with battery storage in it the
rail top cover there are at least half a
dozen different ways to do this this
looks to be mounted off the rear sight
pivot which means you have to remove the
the leaf the adjustable range aspect or
your real rear sight rather and pin on
this top cover so to sort of turn it a
bit into an AKs 74u style Arrangement
and then hopefully lock it in securely
enough at the back that your optic
doesn't shift zero as you use the gun
especially when you open the gun we'll
close it again
foreign
I haven't obviously fought with a 50 BMG
rifle but just just from observation
although although you can control and
shoot this thing from the shoulder if
you're sufficiently strong and all of
that realistically there's a lot of felt
recoil and when your field of view is so
narrow with a scope like this when you
pull the trigger the effect of between
the effect on target of the of the very
powerful Round And The Recoil taking
your crosshairs well off the where they
were point of aim it's almost as if the
targets disappeared and we we see this
in this game depending how far away they
are so when we do see the bullet hit I'm
not sure how projectiles are trapped in
the game but definite one shot does the
job which is what it as it should be a
few things more disappointing in a
shooter than using a big powerful
anti-material rifle and shoot them
um they keep running needless to say
that's not something that could happen
so a game that actually does that and
then what it appears is it's balancing
that out by giving you just five round
magazine and not just forcing you to
only lower five rounds the magazine is
actually a truncated five round capacity
magazine which does which do exist I
don't think they're issued militarily
but they do exist for Barrett rifles
slight cheat I suppose because if you've
got a Barrett there's no real reason why
you wouldn't have a 10 round magazine on
it but giving you just five rounds of
super powerful ammunition to enable you
to have the realistic feeling gameplay I
think is excellent I'm just I'm very
impressed with the way the the Barrett's
depicted here that I don't know what
that armor plate on the back of that
technical was supposed to be in terms of
thickness and hardness and everything
but chances are in reality uh probably
even a ball 50 BMG round would would go
through without too much trouble and
sure enough that's what happens I'm not
sure what the bullet is supposed to be
here but straight through and the guys
dropped so this thing is seriously
impressive in terms of power and it
ought to be
yeah
okay this is a bit of a surprise M1
garen's can't think of a conflict in the
last several decades where I can
remember seeing the M1 still in use as a
rifle of course it's in widespread use
in civilian hands they are going to show
up in Conflict zones in theory unusual
not implausible if one of these things
was knocking around whichever country
this is and someone takes decent care of
it there's no reason why it wouldn't
still work of course these things are
going to keep going for decades in terms
of the model itself it's got a little
bit of Call of Duty itis going on with
that rear sight the aperture is very
very large while I'm in nitpick mode the
This is highly subjective I'm sure
someone could work out how to do this
but pressing in the on block clip from
the rear like that down ergonomically is
rather difficult to have the weapon in
front of you and to just sort of
casually push it in like that in my
experience at least limited as it is you
want it much closer to you and you want
to push straight down into the weapon to
overcome that spring and unlock the
locker clip in place I'm sure someone
has done it this way but with this kind
of weapon bring it bring it closer in
get yourself over it get it loaded and
then get it back up would be my take
interesting so if it's plausible that M1
rifles would still be knocking around as
we say here in the UK
um in this theater I don't think it's
very plausible that a relatively
pristine m1c sniper variant would be
they're pretty rare they'll let them
less likely to survive intact with uh
without oh damn everything from damage
to the conical flash hider to damage to
the scope that would render it basically
useless and you would just get rid of it
I think if an M1 C or D had appeared in
this kind of environment someone would
long ago have got rid of the scope mount
probably and possibly even the flash
hider idea of course of a of a conical
flash hider like this is to hide the
flash it's not breaking up the
combustible gases and preventing them
from from reigniting which is a flash
suppressor does this is literally an old
school cone on the end of a stick like a
Bren and it's just giving you a little
bit of extra length to visit visibly
hide the main brightest bit of The Flash
you're still getting a bit of Flash
makes sense on a second world war
vintage sniper rifle where it's really
acting more like a designated multiple
rifle it's kind of cool to see it in the
game but um it's more Sniper Elite than
Insurgency Sandstorm I would say
ah grease gun specifically at the moment
this type of grease gun so this is not
just a super heavy barrel but what would
it be this is of course a sound
suppressor this distinctive profile this
was developed for the office of
strategic Services the oss the US
counterpart to the Special Operations
executive in the UK there are all sorts
of sneaky beaky type operations the one
in the game has for reasons unknown been
given some sort of handguard sleeve
thing that is a picatilly rail with a
foregrip on it it's not it's not great
in terms of purists like me but in a
model setting people of course do modify
this sort of thing if they're trying to
use it seriously they're going to try to
modernize it although the main thing
you'd want to you'd want to do I think
on a weapon like this is to get some
sort of Red Dot sight onto it and that's
not been done in the the image that I've
got in front of me weirdly and I'll see
if I can see more of this in the
gameplay footage
there seems to be half of a canvas wrap
around this around the hand guard that's
on this bit now that doesn't seem to
make much sense these these um lace-up
webbing covers for suppressors which
were a thing not on ours and I'm not on
the others that I've seen pictures of
and video of if you have one on there
often with asbestos string underneath
them by the way so please be careful if
you happen to come across one they lace
up and they wrap around so half of one
doesn't need to make much sense that's
what I'm
from what I'm getting at
all right so firing this thing looks
good the model of the gun looks good
that nasty seam world around the
receiver halves is is well well
represented we've even got the slight
offset of these uh rivets on the back
here so they're not actually level with
each other one is offset lower than the
other and that's that's been Faithfully
represented the Gun Works as it should
rate of fire is good the way up is
operated my only criticism is very very
minor indeed and it would depend very
much on the individual gun is this
safety slash dust cover here it's a
safety because this tab
blocks the bolt from from moving so you
can't overcome it like on a AR-15 or an
sgg 44 for example you have to manually
open it up and then you
pull the large charging handle to the
rear bolt stays to the rear but the
handle flies back forward under spring
pressure which is
exactly what we see
I think the the crisp Factor seems to be
a bit of a Marmite gun as in people
either love it or hate it I've kind of
torn on it it's
technically speaking the fact that
people are trying to innovate change
designs that basic designs and systems
of operation that we've had for the
better part of a century is great looks
very unusual and cool depending on your
point of view whatever else it does the
fact that it's you know the 45 ACP
variant that we see here very high rate
of fire very controllable again whatever
whatever you to what extent the V rates
or downward recoil system mitigates
recoil which it does but the extent of
that is perhaps arguable regardless of
that it's controllable the the sort of
form factor of the gun and the way
you're able able to sort of handle it
and keep it on target it's very high
rate of fire for a relatively High
recoil cartridge for a pistol cartridge
it's cumulative and we see that with the
the game gun it's it's pushing back
toward the shooter quite drastically but
it's not Rising the muzzle rise is not
it's not drastic and that I think is a
combination of their unusual bolt system
drops down into that big thick housing
underneath rather than coming straight
back helps to push the thing down and
the shape of it is conducive to holding
it down so it in many ways it's the 21st
century Tommy Gun this is probably the
best rendition that I've seen I can't
think of a better one certainly better
than the sort of compromised version
that's in Modern Warfare 2 that's the
wrong shape and size and yeah not as
good as this one
[Applause]
all right the AAC or later q honey
badger always makes me smile because it
of course brings to mind the animal with
the same name which is exactly the
purpose of naming it honey badger sounds
and handles pretty much as you would
expect I haven't haven't shot a honey
badger um have shot a rattler the Sig
equivalent to this thing similar sort of
size and the reporting games versus in
real life is very very hard to sort of
quantify because it depends where you
are and ammunition that you use and
everything like that but this sounds
right The Recoil looks about right as
well so it's going to be pretty
controllable fully automatic in its
military application of course which is
what this is supposed to represent and
it's going to hit pretty hard at close
range with that 300 cartridge I don't
think Sandstorm is modeling sort of
tarkov levels of ammunition types or
anything like that so that would be the
way to make this even more interesting
would be to have different loads for it
yeah subsonic supersonic different
bullet designs to to make it effective
for what you need it for but the honey
badger is designed for 300 seems to work
well with it
right ks23 shotgun we've covered this
before in a different game but this is
this is really good well say that we
don't have one to compare it it's
essentially it's a Soviet era design
massive pump action it's pretty
conventional in mechanical terms not
remarkable in that way other than just
looking like a real unit but
um the key thing is the 23 in the name
so uh 23 millimeter caliber which
equates to I believe it's just over six
gauge now in the the title screen type
the screen the weapon screen there
it's a four gauge which could be
substantially even more massive which I
don't I don't believe that's correct it
should be six or or close to a bit of a
bit of gameplay footage there something
that is not well represented is
breaching so you might you might have
breaching in the sense of you fire
shotgun rounds at your virtual door and
it disappears or breaks or whatever you
don't typically get that what we've just
seen which is blow out top hinge blow
out bottom hinge Doors door falls out
you know that's that's how shotgun
reaching is or one way of doing uh
shotgun breaching the other way of
course being to blow the lock but blow a
hole through the wood and some of the
locker just falls out you know that you
can do that with a shotgun especially a
23 millimeter shotgun
breakfast
again and Jay right mg3 I happen to have
one of these now this is an Iranian
mg3 which is perhaps appropriate for
the the loose setting of this game so of
course the German design and still in
service uh setting up vehicles in the
bundlesware as well Iran operates them
we can see the Persian sight markings
possibly can't on the camera but there
are personal site markings on the rear
side very minor differences other than
that these are mg42s they they're just
mg42s in 762 by 51 uh I mean what can I
say about this that hasn't been said
before it's an absolute beast and I
think that comes across pretty well in
the footage maybe The Recoil isn't
enough because the rate of fire anything
between 700 and 1500 rounds per minute
depending on the bolt you fit to the gun
now in actual service since I think it's
reported to be about 1200 rounds per
minute the figure in front of me here on
the screen is a thousand rounds per
minute which is interesting now having I
haven't timed it exactly but uh our own
mg42 that has been occasionally been
fired um here runs at about 12 100 RPM
what I'm getting at here is I don't
think there is this huge difference in
rate of fire in actual operational
service between the original mg42 and
the mg1 the mg2 the mg3 which are all in
762 by 51. I think that's entirely down
to what bolt is what is entirely down to
what bolt is fitted well I'm sure people
who've served in the bundles were can
confirm or deny but my impression is
this should this probably is actually
running at more like 1200 in the game
and a thousand would be too low I think
anyway splitting hairs because 1 1 000
to 1200 or even the maximum 1500 rounds
per minute
is all insane quite frankly
I would say they've um they've given me
a cursed gun but I I know enough about
this this the man around 73 357 Magnum
Revolver uh to know that that
configuration with a bipod and a scope
and I think that is those are correct
biparton scope as well is in fact a
service configuration for this revolver
amazingly so if you don't know the
French gign counter-terrorist police
military unit they actually as well as
issuing these as sidearms they actually
use them as sniper revolver so this is
exactly the sort of thing we normally
criticize video games for doing they
actually did in real life to to some
effects certainly in the 1970s and 80s
being able to precisely place a pistol
bullet could achieve the effect that a
armed police unit essentially
needed to achieve it's a bit Niche it's
a bit unique but I'm certainly not going
to criticize them for doing that so that
that revolver in the game is configured
in that way
all right this is an odd ball at least
it is outside China because this is the
the Chinese qts 11. I'm gonna have to go
away and do further research on
designations because although I I
broadly understand the Chinese military
system of designation Q meaning
essentially gun and then the other
letters denoting exactly what it is
rifle like machine gun
Etc the opinion Chinese for qts 11 is
something completely different so I
don't know where the qts comes in but
that's what it's called and that's the
designation for this
complete weapon but buried inside this
gun is a type zero three or a
qbz03 5.8 millimeter rifle that's why
the caliber type is list the cartridge
type is listed as 5.8 by 42 that's
correct that's the standard Chinese
military cartridge type but this thing
has relatively compactually mounted into
it piggybacking on top a 20 millimeter
grenade launcher this is that jack of
all trades Holy Grail that people keep
trying to chase like the American
objective infantry combat weapon so I
think the only military force in the
world to be using one of these hybrid
weapons grenade launcher and rifle what
they tend to call the kinetic aspect of
the weapon system is China very
interesting to see it depicted whether
one would show up in a war zone I really
can't say and I really can't say how
well depicted it is either because we
have no experience with either of the
weapons that go to make up this hybrid
design the
explosive effect of the grenades should
be pretty small and it seems to be say
that because it's only 20 millimeters
which is really quite small and 40
millimeters seems to be the sweet spot
for us for a relatively small caliber
grenade system which of course is still
pretty big so that increases the bulk
the weight it gives you problems for any
kind of more than one round feed system
so the only advantage to a 20 or 25 mil
system would be a magazine feed and this
doesn't have it so anyway I'm getting
into a sort of ill-informed critique of
the weapon itself rather than the the
gun in the game but that's because we
don't have access to this technology for
some pretty obvious reasons
Charlie
right the HS product vhs2 Croatian
design we're lucky to have an example of
a VHS K2 here K2 being a carbine version
I think you can see the difference
relative to the game
depiction Barrel is visibly shorter main
reason I mentioned that is that the the
gun in the game is fitted with the
underbarrel launcher which we don't have
unfortunately but it replaces the
handguard and gives you a standard 40
millimeter under Barrel capability the
gun looks good uh it's fitted with the
stanag magazine housing so this has the
the Croatian original which takes not
G36 magazines these are similar in
design to the G36 magazine but they are
not G36 magazine it's not unrealistic
but as provided for Croatian armed
forces and people that don't mind buying
all their magazines again it would look
like this if this has been procured by
whoever for whatever purpose then it
stands to reason they would go for the
AR-15 pattern magazines so that
difference is not in any way an error
um the only other difference I noticed
uh except that the house is too short
because it's a different variant it are
the iron sights so ours have these funky
flip up
back up iron sights built into the rail
I don't know if that's why that's not on
this gun but I'm sure that whichever gun
they used as reference didn't have it
and that's valid too don't know the
answer to that one
if you'd like to support our work at the
Royal armories I think you know the
drills by now but you can check out our
website our various social media
channels our own YouTube channel which
is uh features me as well if you like
that kind of thing and among other
things as well we have a new series
that's launched called up in arms which
includes various other types of arms and
armor but you might see the occasional
guest appearance from me as well if you
do like what I'm doing in particular
um I I can offer a brief tease of an
event that's happening in March here at
the Leeds Museum that will involve me so
more on that keep an eye on our social
media we'll see you again regardless
next time thank you very much
[Music]
foreign
[Music]